>> Mike: OUR TOP STORY AT
THE BOTTOM OF THE HOUR, THE
FBI ADMITS IT FAILED TO
FOLLOW UP ON A TIP LAST
MONTH THAT FLORIDA HIGH
SCHOOL SHOOTER NIKOLAS CRUZ
WAS PLANNING AN ATTACK.
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT SAYS
THIS IS LAUNCHING AN
INVESTIGATION.
FLORIDA REPUBLICAN GOVERNOR
RICK SCOTT CALLING ON FBI
DIRECTOR CHRISTOPHER WRAY TO
RESIGN.
THE FIRST FUNERALS FOR THE
VICTIM IS TODAY.
TONIGHT WE'RE LEARNING MORE
ABOUT SOME OF THEM SENIOR
CORRESPONDENT RICK LEVENTHAL
IS AT POMPEO
IS PT POMPEO
IS POMPOMPEO
IS POMPAMPEO
IS POMPANOEO
IS POMPANO.O
>> MOURNERS GATHER TO
REMEMBER AND BURY SOME OF
THE FIRST VICTIMS.
ALYSSA AHLADEFF 14 YEARS
OLD.
STUDENT AND SOCCER PLAYER.
A BRIGHT LIFE LOST FOREVER.
SO SMART, BEAUTIFUL.
CREATIVE ALWAYS WANTS TO GO
TO THE NEXT EVENT, NEXT
ACTIVITY.
SHE LOVED EVERYBODY, TRUSTED
EVERYBODY.
SHE WAS AN AMAZING SOCCER
PLAYER.
>> LET'S CONTINUE TO PRAY
EVERY DAY, EVERY NIGHT.
>> THURSDAY NIGHT THOUSANDS
GATHERED FOR A VIGIL NEAR
THE HIGH SCHOOL.
HOLDING CANDLES AND SIGNS.
MANY OPENLY SOBBING AS THE
NAMES OF THE VICTIMS WERE
READ.
SPEAKERS INCLUDED THE FATHER
OF 14-YEAR-OLD JAMIE
GUTTENBERG.
>> JAMIE WAS SUCH A SPECIAL
KID.
ALL OF THE KIDS HERE ARE.
WHAT IS UNFATHOMABLE IS
JAIME TOOK A BULLET AND IS
DEAD.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT I DO NEXT.
MY WIFE IS HOME.
WE ARE BROKEN.
>> FRESHMAN HALEY BETANCOURT
WHO HEARD THE GUNFIRE
WEDNESDAY SPOKE TO MARCH
THAN MACCALLUM AFTER THE
VIGIL.
>> I WAS CRYING THE WHOLE
TIME BUT IT WAS REALLY HARD
TO TAKE IN BECAUSE YOU HEAR
YOUR FRIENDS' NAMES AND THEN
I LOST 8 FRIENDS.
>> THREE OF THE DEAD WERE
TEACHERS OR COACHES,
INCLUDING AARON FEIS WHO
WORKED WITH THE FOOTBALL
TEAM AND AS A SECURITY
GUARD.
BEING REMEMBERED AS A HERO
FOR USING HIS BODY TO SHIELD
STUDENTS FROM THE BULLETS.
>> IT'S ACTUALLY REALLY HARD
TO TALK ABOUT COACH RIGHT
NOW.
THE HARDEST PART WILL BE
DRIVING THROUGH THE FRONT
GATES AND NOT SEEING COACH
FEIS SITTING THERE, GIVING
ME A THUMBS UP OR MAKING ME
STOP TO ROLL THE WINDOW DOWN
AND SAYING THAT, YOU KNOW,
HE CARES ABOUT ME OR HAVE A
GOOD DAY AT SCHOOL OR GET MY
STUFF DONE BECAUSE I'M A
KNUCKLE HEAD OR SOMETHING
LIKE THAT.
>> MEANWHILE AT THIS VERY
MOMENT, MIKE, THE
PRESIDENT'S MOTORCADE IS
ARRIVING HERE AT BROWARD
HEALTH NORTH MEDICAL CENTER.
WE'RE TOLD THAT THE
PRESIDENT AND FIRST LADY
WILL BE MEETING WITH DOCTORS
AND OTHER HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS HERE WHO
HELPED SAVE LIVES U THERE
ARE THREE VICTIMS STILL
BEING TREATED HERE AT
BROWARD HEALTH NORTH.
TWO IN FAIR CONDITION.
ONE IN CRITICAL THAT PATIENT
IS SAID TO BE IMPROVING.
THREE OTHER SHOOTING VICTIMS
ARE STILL RECOVERING AT
BROWARD MEDICAL IN FORT
LAUDERDALE.
ONE WAS RELEASED FROM THERE
EARLIER TODAY, MIKE.
THE SON-IN-LAW OF A
SHERIFF'S DEPUTY WHO IS SAID
TO BE RECOVERING AND HEALING
FROM THIS POINT ON AT HOME.
AGAIN, THE PRESIDENT
ARRIVING HERE AT BROWARD
HEALTH AT THIS MOMENT TO
MEET WITH DOCTORS AND OTHER